foreign
[Music]
as easily as smartphones roam cellular
networks what if built-in security could
adapt quickly and intelligently to
application behaviors across clouds
what if you could achieve speed
Simplicity and security at the same time
it's time to redefine how your
applications are connected secured and
delivered
it's time for a new network paradigm
it's time for cross-cloud networking
good morning and welcome everyone this
is I know an early morning show
I had asked for a time later in the day
and they tell me no networking is so
important it's a fabric that
interconnects and makes all gcp
applications work so we want your
undivided retention you get the morning
slot uh I am maninder Singh samvi uh
vice president and general manager here
at Google Cloud for cloud networking and
along with me I'm going to have my
colleague Nicol Kel Shaker and we have
customers like Walmart sharechat and
Alex from broadcom that will be talking
and joining me on stage here
now you saw the video Cloud networking
is a thing it's real and it's now and
I'm here today in my session very
excited to share some news and updates
on what Google is doing to address this
evolving need of cross-cloud networking
with Google cross Cloud Network
as you all know roughly about 64 percent
of Enterprises have already deployed
multi-cloud strategies
and there's a new inflection point with
AIML that's going to fundamentally
transform not just the way we live but
also how we work in our workspace
AIML is going to fundamentally change
our entire experience right from the
time we get up we deploy applications
and we go back
with the growth of AIML
we believe that fundamentally how you
build deliver and secure your
applications is going to be very
different on how it's done today
a very early research from analysts have
suggested that 31 of developers are
going to look at a new Cloud to leverage
gen AI capabilities so the notion of
multi-cloud is going to be much more
complex much more hard to achieve and we
want to make sure we simplify all of
this for you
now cyber security is super important
especially in the cloud
last year 76 percent of Enterprises got
a breach
and an estimation of about 3.5 million
is what an average cost of the breach
for was for an Enterprise and obviously
depending on the breach and ransomware
it could be north of 100 plus million at
times
we do believe cyber security should be
front and center
on an average data proc data says that
there's roughly about 560
000 new malware that are seen on a daily
basis you can imagine the volume of
cyber attacks the sophistication of
these attacks because they are using
AIML technology to create variants
faster than what your firewalls your
traditional firewalls can keep up with
and here at Google we fundamentally
believe security should be built in
should not be an afterthought it should
be part of everything that we do you
want to be able to secure it and network
security is fundamental to anything that
you do as part of your Cloud security
because Network sees all data all
application transactions that go through
and it's the right place to enforce your
security policies
now today's
really not done
meet the needs of AIML multi-cloud or
security
as an Enterprise you've already built
out hybrid connectivity paradigms
connecting your data centers your
co-location architectures into the cloud
making it easier for you to migrate
on-prem to the cloud but you've also
invested bespoke infrastructure to
connect to every cloud that you are
using
in addition to that
you're also looking at a investing in
front ends for your internet facing
applications whether it be from a cloud
provider or from any other caching
engine and a variety of other vendors
that might be available
last but not least your hybrid Workforce
is the norm we all are working through a
hybrid Workforce how do you make sure
that you can apply security policies as
you deploy SSE
these are all bespoke Networks
that individually you have to invest
manage very cumbersome from an
operational perspective and each of
these networks per C has one limiting
factor you either have the Best in Class
security and you compromise on
application experience or you try to
optimize for application experience and
you go with good enough security
and we don't like that we want to make
sure that you are do not have any
compromise between application
experience and security and because
you're building bespoke networks with
inconsistent security and the
operational burden your TCO is much
higher than what you would have
anticipated down the journey
what we would like to introduce today
it's cross Cloud Network it's an open
platform
it provides you ml powered security
that's built in for everything that you
do
and it's performance optimized to ensure
that your application gets the best
experience whether it's for users that
are connecting to your e-commerce
websites or for your users your
employees connecting to private apps
that are hosted in cloud or SAS
applications that you might be consuming
the cross Cloud network is an open
platform
that helps you secure
provide consistent security
as well as lower your TCO
sorry
it's an open platform because you can
bring in any vendor any ecosystem
partner that you're working with
and engage that partner as part of this
journey we are not asking you to rip and
replace your existing infrastructure or
your existing security vendor you can
bring it onto the platform you can use
the same security policies that you're
used to and apply them in the cloud
it's an open platform because all
developers want to be able to extract
the complexity of networking and move to
our services networking layer to State
service a to communicate to service b in
a secure and simple manner
consistent security we want to provide
consistent security across all the three
use cases that I talked about whether it
be co-locations that are applications
connecting to the cloud whether it be
your front ends
or it'd be hybrid Workforce that's
actually accessing internet SAS and
private applications
and we can all we can do all of this
because it's backed by Google's largest
backbone
the planet scale Network that we have
let me tell you what the planet scale
network is all about
all Google services that you see search
YouTube and and the niceness of all the
Google services that we offer runs on
this backbone
it's the it has the largest global
footprint that you can find 38 regions
187 Network edges subsea cable
Investments that we've done there's
billions and billions of dollars that we
have spent we have 200 plus countries
and territories we actually have Edge
locations to host and provide you that
experience from a global application
perspective
the same network that is powering all of
Google services
can now be leveraged by our customers
for their own infrastructure
which is high performance scale and
application optimized
imagine five times the size of the
internet at your fingertips
that's what the Google backbone has to
offer
as we embark on the Journey of cross
Cloud Network the three major use cases
that we are going to be focusing on
how do you build distributed
applications
and make it simple when you're
interconnecting your clouds
how do you deliver some of these
applications from an internet facing
through a global front-end use case
and along the way how do you secure
access for your hybrid Workforce so I'm
going to go into each one of these use
cases in a bit more detail
I talked about the bespoke networks that
you're building and you see the network
diagram with co-location or data centers
that are actually connecting into the
cloud and multiple clouds
making it extremely complex as well as a
much higher TCO
with cross Cloud Network
we will now be able to provide you on
demand any to any connectivity
where you can actually connect AWS Azure
and the likes of others directly into
Google Cloud
without having to invest in physical
infrastructure and manage that life
cycle of the infrastructure
we'll be able to provide you 20 times
higher threat efficacy along the way
whether your application from cloud a is
trying to connect to a VM or a gke
cluster in gcp you can simply and easily
add in a firewall and connect to it
along this lines we will also be able to
provide 40 TCO savings
now how do we do this you see a list of
products that we are introducing the
first one being cross Cloud Network
interconnect this is a managed in uh
internet that we're providing with an
SLA bagged it's secure
it comes in various variants of 10 gig
and 100 gigs and multiples of it
depending on how much traffic and data
that you're looking to move
we also have
the the customers who are backing it up
with Walmart Fortune one and obviously
Yahoo mail and I'll talk about what each
one of these customers are doing
when you look at this particular
infrastructure we want to make sure that
you are leveraging the power of what
cross Cloud network has to build each
one of these products even though
they're unique Innovations they're all
tied together making it simple and easy
and consistent for you to use cross
Cloud Network
obviously we can't do this alone we have
Partners like BT and equinix BT
obviously we partner a lot as we build
out our Global backbone
in order to provide you high performance
and scale globally
we also have the likes of Yahoo mail and
you might have seen this in Thomas's
keynote yesterday hundreds and millions
of mailboxes and the amount of data that
they're going to be moving into the
cloud is not possible without actually
having a direct connect between the
clouds and being ensuring that it's SLA
backed and secure along the way
I'm sure a lot of you use Yahoo mail and
as you use Yahoo mail I'm sure you're
worried about what happens to my data
now this is a modern way for actually
delivering some of these applications
we recommend in our opinion from a
Google perspective that the services
based architecture is the best
with private service connect you can
actually have a producer and a consumer
construct
and you can seamlessly abstract the
underlying complexity of networking and
connect to any SAS application whether
it be vertex AI it'd be spanner Cloud
SQL is something that we just announced
earlier this week
the likes of alloy DB and others
now this is a very simple way for you to
connect your producers and consumers The
Producers could be in any other Cloud
could be on-prem and could seamlessly
Connect into a gcp service
not only that we have an open ecosystem
with mongodb Snowflake and the likes of
others that if you would like to use in
gcp you can connect your applications
that might be hosted in any other cloud
we fundamentally believe we have to meet
the customer in the Journey of cloud and
every customer has a different Journey
I'm sure you started some of you started
with different clouds and started
developing applications it's hard to
move those applications but you want to
use the goodness of what Google has to
offer and the open ecosystem that we
offer with our partners and seamlessly
connect back into that into your
applications
especially around vertex a I'm sure you
saw the demo yesterday super exciting
so how do you Leverage The Power of AIML
and The Innovation that Google brings
and leverage it for the application that
you've already developed
obviously there might be some customers
who might say I don't like the producer
consumer construct
you can also do the same and achieve the
same through an application load
balancer
and obviously for folks who are hardcore
networking they like routing we offer
that too with our NCC product family you
can do route exchanges you can address
any overlapping addresses that might be
and we can now interconnect your on-prem
your clouds or other categories as well
now I talked about how important
security is so be really pleased to
announce Cloud ngfw which provides 20
times higher threat efficacy than anyone
else in the industry from a cloud
perspective
this is the test that we ran with
critical high and medium vulnerabilities
across exploits command and control as
well as malware
and we have a very high efficacy that we
see not only did we get the best
intelligence from mandiant as well as
our partner Palo Alto networks we also
made it very simple
we have now offering high performance
TLS decryption in our data plane without
any impact to the firewall because we've
taken that function and embedded it into
our virtual stack
you can integrate this particular file
without having to make any routing
changes and I'm sure you've all
struggled as Network Engineers on if I
need to deploy a firewall and animic
apply comply with my security policies
as an Enterprise how do I do that easily
and simply we absolutely be able to
offer that as well
we also allow you to do tag based
policies you can tag a workload or a
database store and you can set this
particular store applies with a security
policy a and we will automatically take
care of that
I'm also very pleased to announce we are
the first ones in the industry to
actually announce something
beyond what a cloud ngfw would do around
network security posture control
this is basically being able to apply
security policies at an org level so
that you have individual projects that
your different business units might be
adhering to
each one of them get consistent policy
and cannot change that particular policy
because that's controlled
at the same time we also provide IEM
provision tags and a layered incident
report for sock we're really pleased
with what we have done here from a
security perspective making it simple
consistent and easy for you to be able
to connect distributed applications
from any cloud or on-prem to to leverage
the services that gcp has to offer
with this I'll invite Gerald and nikhil
to come join me on stage
good morning General
good morning
thanks for having us here
um yes so everyone knows Walmart largest
retailer in the world Fortune one
company we're really happy to have
General here on stage I just want to
start off General I'm sure the Republic
here would like to know what is Google
Walmart's Cloud strategy and how is it
evolving sure sure so uh as many know we
we went on this journey of the
multi-cloud the multi-cloud journey is
the multi-cloud setup that we have is
basically uh three cloud service
providers across three regions across
the us so we go across the west region
the central region and the east region
right
uh the whole aim of this is to enable uh
our customers to move workloads
and place them in places in the cloud
service providers that enables best of
breed Services it provides low latency
provides better application performance
so we leveraged our private Cloud which
is a fairly large size of about million
CPU cores plus we use Google Cloud
platform and we use a third-party cloud
service provider as well
so that's a little short summary of our
multi-cloud strategy which goes across
the three regions that's a very complex
Cloud strategy I'm sure working with
different vendors it's very hard to
stitch all of this together what are the
challenges that you've seen
that have inhibited you to accelerate
your speed of innovation that's correct
it is challenging uh our goal the main
goal of the multi-cloud strategy is to
accelerate Innovation and provide value
to our customers in the stores and
online right with uh
stable and high reliability numbers so
that was our main goal to go in this
direction the challenges we were running
into is we we set up our private clouds
very strategically across the Us close
to our customers right so we wanted to
reduce the latency so now from the
private clouds we could reach uh the
connectivity to Google or the
connectivity to the public clouds we
have the private connectivity
connectivity available right within the
connects
the challenge came where you have to go
public Cloud to public cloud
interconnectability and our goal was to
keep it at low latency so that our
customers are not impacted with latency
right so that's uh that was one of the
challenges and then the other one was uh
when you're going from the old way which
we had was yet to go from one cloud
provider to our power point of presence
and then hooked into back into the other
cloud provider right so you're going
around this hairpin which created
latency plus you're having the addition
of managing your pops the egress cost
all that adds up
wow so Gerald that's when you reached
out to us and we started working on
cross-cloud interconnect and you were
one of the earliest adopters of this
product so tell me what was valuable in
that partnership and how is walmarty
leveraging this sure sure so yes we were
uh
we reached out to you guys and you
always it was super helpful the
collaboration was great uh we wanted to
go from a public cloud provider to
Google directly by awarding The Hop so
this helped us to reduce the latency uh
it gives us a solid reliability of 99.99
percent plus it reduces the cost for us
and it helps one hop and egress out
coming out from our pop so all in all
this helps us a whole lot right now and
we can do this across the region so we
do this in east west and Central all
right thank you
you heard munender talk about the cross
Cloud Network you have seen the
presentation you have a little bit of a
preview how are you going to take
advantage of some of the other new
capabilities like PSC and security and
all of these in your roadmap going
forward what are your thoughts so when
we build this connectivity between the
clouds our goal is not to just use it
for Network right so we want to leverage
and push the bar uh or raise the bar I
would say so now we plan to use this for
storage we plan to use this for the new
Google apis that are being released out
to go across the cloud providers and we
also plan to use this for all the AIML
data that goes across these clouds so as
you guys release more services we're
going to keep pushing it
perfect thank you General good luck
thank you nikhil
thank you looking forward to the
partnership so so nikhil like everyone
here probably is wondering hey cross
loud networking is a thing is it real
can I see your demo
yes absolutely thank you munender so as
you talked about cross-cloud networking
vertex Ai and everything and I'm going
to try to bring this to life let me set
up the demo it's a recording but what we
are going to see is we have an
application running in ec2 which is
going to call a Vertex AI
backend over the Internet first and then
we are going to migrate that application
and make it work over a cross-loud
network so you can do this privately
so with that in mind let's take a look
first
I'm just entering my name and I'm asking
the model through this chat bot this is
actually running in ec2 at this point
who are you it is actually response back
saying that it's the Palm 2 model
running in vertex AI on gcp
let's ask you to write a poem about
Cloud networking of course this person
is thinking and has written some Rhymes
which if you are careful LL Cool J will
be rhyming to later tonight at the party
so make sure you go to the party so now
that we've seen that we are going to
migrate this over to cross Cloud
networking what we are going to do is
you have AWS we have a cross Cloud
interconnect in between a PSE endpoint
which talks to vertex AI you need to do
this so you can actually privately move
the data
from where closest to the so that can
learn and be able to deliver this
securely
now once this is all set up we have
actually accelerated it and I'm going to
walk you through a couple of screens AWS
console where you have a direct connect
running in Frankfurt region this is in
AWS it is pre-configured if we try to do
it in real time it will take time
and if the Google console we have a
corresponding interconnect Port which is
also in Frankfurt region we have
established bgp sessions between both of
these so that you can now communicate
directly from gcp to AWS we can do this
over CCI even with Azure oci and others
and now that it is done we are going to
set up a PSE endpoint we reserve an IP
address for private service connect
which can be used for this particular
application
once that IP address is reserved we
actually set up the PSC forwarding rule
to vertex AI
and that's the next command
once that is done we should have
connectivity between gcp and ec2
instance which can now privately over
CCI connect and reach out to vertex AI
so all the communication is secure
and done over a high bandwidth
sle-backed Network
we'll flip over to the AWS console where
you have a route back to the 10.10
network the private Network RFC 1980
Network back to the gcp forwarding Rule
and now
to conclude let's ask you to write
another poem about crossover networking
this time and
there you go
so what you have seen is that we can
establish private connectivity to gcp
from any cloud and allow high bandwidth
SLA bagged
capability so you can move the data to
where the application or the SAS service
resides and be able to deliver this in a
very efficient manner and that brings
cross-cloud Network to life perfect this
is awesome thank you plus for nikhil and
general
if you're looking to write poems using
vertex AI or develop new applications
you can do it in a much simpler and easy
way which we believe is the modern way
of what networking would look like in
the cloud
do keep in mind like this is just the
start of a journey
and as nickel pointed out it is so easy
to establish connectivity as a producer
consumer construct using PSE not having
to worry about underlying complex
infrastructures route exchanges I mean
those are important but this is a much
more easier simpler way of providing the
service
now coming to my next use case we're
going to deliver front-end applications
how do you do that
you have multiple multiple front ends
when you're looking to go Global
capacity reasons capability reasons and
you might have multiple vendors that
you're working with
we want to be able to introduce a cross
sound Network that actually delivers the
global front-end with ML power security
our Cloud armored product the first in
the industry to actually have being able
to leverage
ml models to be able to protect against
massive DDOS attacks and you might have
seen some announcements that you've done
in the LA in the last couple of you know
12 months
you also hear broadcom at the show
theater actually talk about how Cloud
armor has helped them prevent many of
these DDOS attacks so please go listen
to them you'll realize what the value
we're bringing in how our ml models are
able to mitigate some of these attacks
the second biggest Advantage obviously
is 240 cost saving as you consolidate
this multi-product from CDN to Global
load balancer to the ability to for
supporting ml powered security with uh
Cloud armor you can now consolidate all
these capability in the single unit and
be able to consume it globally at the
global backbone footprint that Google
has to offer
we also invested a lot in terms of
customization and programmability
because we all we fundamentally believe
that every customer is different even
though you might have a web application
based on your vertical needs you want to
be able to have that level of
customization for your web application
so very pleased to announce the service
extension
capability on a global load balancer
it's it's it allows you to inherent and
customize your web application and we
see at a data plane level seamlessly
being able to integrate it with any
third party offering that might be there
so you see partner solutions from a
security logging monitoring you can do
customizations from a message uh
transformation or traffic routing we're
partnering with human traceable bright
insight and Landis gear
this is amazing whereas you bring all of
this together with the programmability
cable they're making it easier so I
would like to now invite
our share chat customer
gaurav to come on stage
and give us a brief overview
welcome gaurav thank you
[Applause]
thanks a lot
um excited for you to be here I know you
flew all the way from India as many of
you might not know I think it'll be
helpful God if you could just explain
what sharechat is about and the level of
scale and performance that you have seen
in terms of subscribers and the
complexity in your business sure yeah
thanks Melinda thanks for delighted to
be here so uh sharechat is basically
India's largest homegrown social network
we are humbled that every month more
than 350 million users come to us to
share content Express discover Trends
opportunities and then build communities
and we are have been on this journey
with gcp for a long time and uh you know
really excited to be part of it yeah
and I think share chat I mean the level
of scale the level of subscribers you
can see you can't really you need a
backbone you need the platform and the
global edges that are globally available
can you tell me something more about
your architecture because the level of
skills that you're operating at there's
a very few companies just like the
fortune one Walmart complexity and
distributed applications how does your
architecture have to evolve how is it
today and how how does it have to evolve
yeah so one of the unique things about
shared chat as a social network is that
you know what we allow the users to do
is engage with the platform in the
language that they're most comfortable
in right so we support 15 different
languages uh Indian languages and
um essentially what happens is that when
you look at the scale we're talking
about serving close to 300 billion video
views you know and um and so massive
scale you know we're talking about like
half a million requests per second at
our Peak
um so the core infrastructure the back
end is built on microservices running in
GT okay we use both Google managed
Services as well as self-hosted services
on the client side of course it's
Android iOS web applications but more
importantly at that scale the content
delivery is a very important problem
that we have had to solve so if the way
we've solved is is it is we've got
multiple different CDN vendors that we
work with Google
media CDN being one of the key pillars
and you know it's a very unique and
challenging problem in the sense that
we've got users who are coming on a very
poor Network maybe from some remote
Village from a 50 device all the way to
like you know fifteen thousand fifteen
hundred dollar iPhone so there is a huge
range of device types Network types and
so what we do is we've built a system
where in real time we detect how
different cdns are performing we
continuously monitor them and then based
on the network or the ISP that the user
is coming from
um you know their
IP NGO location and what kind of
performance they're getting on a
different CDN we dynamically route them
to those to the best CDN that's possible
uh because you know as you can imagine
uh for us the user experience uh and you
know our content is text video uh short
form video long form video images
um you know some of the key metrics
really drive the user experience and the
user attention so how quickly a video
plays uh what the buffering is like what
the error rate is like all those have a
very direct impact on our user
experience and consequently our business
metrics right so we have seen that even
you know 20 millisecond differences will
cause users to drop off
um and so we've really really optimized
for that around and and Cloud CDN has
been you know one of our great Partners
on the media Syrian and we and we do
appreciate it I mean this is amazing
that your entire business model works on
ensuring that the experience is met
right it's amazing like
um can you you heard about class Cloud
Network you saw what I talked about in
terms of global front end how would you
how do you see a road map evolving yeah
so for us I think the main thing you
know when we look at ourselves as a
business it's all about you know user
engagement user growth so there's a lot
of innovation happening there but there
is also a very important element of
um building a business which is very
cost efficient and uh and we want to get
the best of breed from all the different
Cloud vendors
um and so in that sense like you know
class Cloud networking fits in really
well because we've looked at uh you know
we've been multi-cloud from a cloud cdns
uh viewpoint but from the point of view
of like other workloads that's something
we want to experiment with very active
so I'm quite excited about Cloud uh you
know cross Cloud
um you know of course being uh you know
custodian of a lot of the users
um you know information we definitely
you know take security very seriously so
I'm very excited about you know the
simply verification that a lot of the
services that you've talked about will
bring in here so that's an important
area for us as well and in general you
know compute and scaling it a very cost
efficient manner is an important aspect
for us because that really helps us uh
build build a strong business where you
know the cost to serve the user is is
contained and you know the users get a
very good experience yeah perfect this
is really helpful as you heard like here
chat social media whether it be vods
live streaming super apps whether you're
trying to do shots user experience is so
damn important to get this this right
and security along the way is going to
be really really important so if you
have similar applications where
experience is important cross Cloud
Network can definitely help you make it
sure that the delivery for the
application is optimal it's secured
along the way and if you have to
customize your application with any
third party we absolutely allow that as
an opening system big round of applause
for URL and thank you gaurav
uh going to my third use case this is
about hybrid Workforce we want to make
sure we extend the same level of
capabilities to our hybrid Workforce
whether they're working or from a remote
user from a branch or a campus
interconnecting through your co-location
or through your data centers
now here we obviously want to build on
the open ecosystem that we have today
whenever you're trying to deliver this
service for your employees you have to
choose between security or an
application experience it's very hard I
mean these are employees and the result
in direct productivity impact if the
application experience is not that great
especially as more and more applications
get into a SAS form how do you provide
that seamless security that can go with
the user independent of where he or she
connects from
we're very pleased to announce some
Partnerships here from our SSE stack we
have Palo Alto networks with Prisma
access then that is now hosted and it's
almost in terms of thinking of it in
your VPC so not only are you deploying
it for app to app communication you can
now also extend that to be able to
deploy for a user to app or user to
internet or user to SAS kind of an
application we also work with other ngfw
vendors so that we know for a fact there
might be customers in different Journeys
they might be looking at an SSC stack
well at other times you might be looking
at a traditional ngfw stack we partner
with the market leaders starting from 49
Cisco Palo Alto networks as well as
checkpoint
and the challenge obviously is how do I
connect my branches and bring the
traffic and land the traffic onto the
gcp network
and we work with all sd-wan vendors any
branch any router that you might have
whether it be from Cisco from juniper
and the likes of others we can bring and
onboard that and seamlessly integrate
and we've launched this about two years
ago with the sd-wan integration as well
open ecosystem the advantage you get is
consistent security at the same time you
get 35 percent Improvement in user
experience and that's predominantly
because depending on where the SAS
application is hosted it traverses the
Google backbone which is secure high
performance and globally available
internet on the other hand you can do
this very similarly across the Internet
it's unreliable you don't actually have
an SLA security you will have to put
your own security Hooks and it's
unpredictable
so with this class or network you can
now bring in your hybrid Workforce and
give them the same level of experience
that you would want and with this I
would like to invite one of our partners
that we've been working very closely
with Alex from Symantec by broadcom
good morning Alex
[Applause]
how's it going it's going good
um as you can see I'm sure our audience
is wondering hey we've started on this
journey of cross Cloud Network how
important hybrid Workforce is if you can
just outline like at broadcom how you
are looking to secure with your SSC
stack uh the hybrid Workforce and how
you can provide consistent security with
no compromise to application experience
as we go into that discussion I kind of
want to talk a little bit about how we
even got here in the last four years
right you know you can't talk about the
current implementation and the desire
for a lot of large Enterprise
organizations well talking about what
happened four years ago you know prior
to four years ago everybody was on a
path to digital transformation
um but covet hit and it got rapidly
accelerated
so four years ago you heard a lot heard
a lot about zero trust sassy and then
subsequently SSE and that was really to
take the workforce remote
and be able to implement security
controls in with a great user experience
in the same way that Hub and spoke
security had existed for you know
probably over a decade prior to that
now as we move four years
forward to the present everybody's
coming back on premises but not fully
right The New Normal is hybrid and the
challenge there is really taking a look
at what was implemented from a hub and
spoke perspective as well as a
cloud-centric implementation for
security and really combining them
because the the biggest challenge for
our customers for all customers or all
the users is that when you are trying to
implement security the the biggest enemy
to that is complexity
when your applications are sitting
within DC's sitting in SAS
sitting in private data centers sitting
in public cloud and you're implementing
security measures with different types
of policies and different types of
products uh in different paths for from
a network perspective it causes that
complexity causes abilities to
to enable those 74 percent of breaches
for organizations so so that's how we're
approaching we have been approaching it
at Symantec over the last four years was
uh you know implementing sassy and SSE
in such a way that enabled our customers
to be able to to
implement the same policy controls
invisibility regardless of where those
applications have been
with CCN that that accelerates it CCN is
effectively sassy on steroids the
ability to have a single stack sitting
there that that allows you to traffic
cop your network and then having your
single security policy set of security
policies whether to data or threat
hanging off of that regardless of where
your applications are and regardless of
where your users are is very powerful
I like your tagline CCN enables sassy on
steroids with no compromise to
application experience now we can't end
the talk unless we talk about AIML you
heard about all the goodness and the
innovations that you're bringing from an
eiml perspective do you have any plans
to use some of this in your product to
enhance that user experience in the
security efficacy absolutely semantic
has been you know at the Forefront of
AIML over the last two decades uh you
know we introduce things around data
security or using Vector machine
learning you know more than more than a
decade ago uh the idea now is really
taking it to the next level right you
know your threat actors are are already
looking at things like generative AI to
really kind of just celebrate their
ability to put out malware and such
on the flip side all of the security
vendors including Symantec are also
looking at that to protect to help
protect against it and so being able to
Leverage The partnership that we have
with Google
um you know again another history lesson
after uh after Google joined broadcom we
moved our entire infrastructure to
Google
semantic is 100 Google you know a Google
Cloud customer as well as a partner and
because of that we're able to leverage a
lot of those Technologies and we're work
we've been working with Google over the
last I would say nine months especially
specifically on Tech Palm
so we're really excited can't can't
quite can't quite announce it just yet
but next next month we're going to be
announcing the the you know our ability
to our our semantic AI which is built
upon SEC Palm for yes that is exactly
what we want our customers I'm sure
everyone's wondering here SEC Palm is
going to be a real big example of how
our customers are using the goodness of
what Google has to offer from an AIML
perspective integrated into their
products and offer The Best of Beauty
capabilities and it hangs right off of
CCN yeah thank you Alex
thank you
[Applause]
I like what Gerald ended with
CCN enabled sassian steroids consistent
security no compromise to application
experience
now in summary cross Cloud Network
obviously you know we can have up to 35
percent user experience up to 40 percent
lower total cost of ownership with no
compromise to security with 20 times
higher threat efficacy than ever before
we also have Priceline that you might
hear in future some of the other
Keynotes they'll talk about how they're
leveraging cross-cloud networking and
how important it is and they're going to
leverage some of the capabilities that I
talked about in their infrastructure as
well
in addition to cross Cloud Network we
also have
a bunch of new Innovations I think
yesterday you might have heard Thomas
talk about titanium offload system that
basically provides high performance for
C3 VM family we have other innovations
that are coming in Flight that we are
announcing and launching they obviously
help you make your cross Cloud
infrastructure much more simpler and
easy and consistent to use
now the future of cross Cloud networking
is simple
we believe that it's all about
Simplicity and having the network to
meet your needs wherever and whenever
you need it and that's the role of the
network
everyone will need cross-cloud
networking and Google cross Cloud
Network gets you there faster helps you
innovate faster helps you deploy
application experience with no
compromise to security
last in closing I just want to point out
Google cross Cloud Network the right way
to network your Cloud it's a new way to
cloud and I'm sure you're wondering what
can I do next my key takeaway would be
cross Cloud Network and open platform
with ML power security and performance
optimized
um there are additional tracks that go
into details of each one of these use
cases that I would encourage all of you
to go visit and learn and lastly we
understand that every customer is in a
different journey in the cloud and we
are here to help and answer your
questions we would love to co-develop
many of these capabilities that I talked
about because this is a start of a new
era in Cloud networking and we believe
cross Cloud Network and networking is
going to be real it's a thing it's now
and we want to partner with each one of
you as we develop the next phases of
cross Cloud Network so we are actually
announcing something where we want to
partner and co-develop with our
customers want to understand your needs
your journey to ensure that we develop
innovations that can help you accelerate
your speed of innovation with no
compromise to security and application
experience
thank you very much thank you for
attending the session
[Applause]
foreign